hey guys I am in a beautiful Boston I
just arrived at the food and nutrition
conference and Expo here to check out
some of the most delicious and
nutritious snacks in the market and I'm
gonna give you a little sneak peek so
let's do this I literally snacked my way
through the conference and was mucho
full by the time I got on the plane to
go home but I brought home a bag full of
goodies to show you guys some of my
favorite tastiest pace
so first whoo plenty of bye enjoy life
they're crunchy they're light they're
also gluten free if you're gluten
intolerance so this is awesome when you
need a that ton chip fix but the only
have 100 calories so whoo yes top IQ
popped sorghum like a kettle corn
so sorghum is a gluten free whole grain
that is delicious it can be popped kind
like popcorn as you can see it's like
like popcorn for ants
and honestly so delish lots of fibers
and protein yum yum yum yum yum
let's see dig in my bag these are
pressed by kind these bars are just
veggies and fruit honestly the
ingredients are so clean like this one
is pineapple banana apple kale spinach
that's it in just over a hundred
calories when you get four grams of
fiber hemp heart Stoppers they're
Canadian
I love calm parts as they are but these
ones are kind of flavored so they're
great for putting on your you know your
oatmeal or your yogurt and a quarter cup
you get ten grams of protein you get
three grams of fiber plus Omega threes
awesome well I went to town at this one
I got like tons of flavors so these are
amazing
these are enlightened broad beans they
initial pack they come tweet and savory
each packet get a hundred calories seven
grams of protein five grams of fiber
comma
Ellendale few cups they're like quinoa
in a cup this is great for when you're
kind of on the go
it's the southwestern barbecue flavor
because already flavored you don't have
to do anything just put some water in
one cup has 220 calories we've got 7
grams of fiber 7 grams of protein so
anyone that knows me knows I'm obsessed
with caramel this premier protein
caramel protein shake so good 30 grams
of protein 160 calories and just 5 grams
of carbs hello I seriously got one trick
this all day every day
mmm mmm Sun speeds they're basically
nature's candy one pack 100 calories you
get 2 grams of protein in two grams of
fiber and seriously they taste like
candy now go turn it off so these
Mediterra
savory bars are awesome it's kind of fun
to see granola bars move in the more
savory direction and this is so good
sun-dried tomato and basil 140 calories
what else 5 grams of fiber 5 grams of
protein savory bars are the way to go
these Vienna chickpea snacks need more
of these in my life they're crispy
they're not dry that's super flavorful
one of these little packs 150 calories 6
grams of protein 7 grams of fiber
put it on your salad eat it like a snack
you need this monk pack first of all for
the chipmunk on the front which is an
automatic win in my books but this is
oatmeal in a squeeze tube and honestly
it's so good if you're on the go or you
like you're camping and you just need
something quick 90 calories for this
thing 2 grams of protein 3 grams of
fiber plus part healthy Omega threes so
this is a winner
these are addictive addictive simply
protein crunch honestly it's like the
best snack mix one bag is a hundred
calories seven grams of fiber ten grams
of protein this one is banana caramel
cashew so good basically it tastes like
a sundae this one's raspberry and
coconut sprinkle that on to your yogurt
or just eat it as is oh yeah love it
rx bars honestly if these things I've
heard about them for so long and I never
got to taste them until I went to the
conference we always talk about protein
bars having so many ingredients these
are just egg whites nuts dates and no BS
it says right there on the package so it
must be true so good crazy
Richards 100% peanut powder I'm obsessed
with peanut butter like to the max and
this stuff has 2 grams of fiber 6 grams
of protein and just 50 calories per
package and you can throw it on to you
know put in your smoothies or put on
your yogurt and your oatmeal me and PB
so guys I hope you enjoyed my healthy
snack haul I tried a ton of snacks over
that weekend and these ones were the
cream of the crop my personal favorites
so I'm gonna know what some of your
favorite healthy snacks are so leave me
a comment below also if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen dig
down